I often see people comment stuff when
they're single where they say things
like I don't need nobody you don't we
have our own I don't need a man I don't
need a man huh
but guess what I want you and that's the
Dibble what's one of those things that
you really enjoyed learning about him
that was like really different the thing
that's different about him is that it's
not about him being better he's still a
man yeah but it's the loyalty that I
like oh you know I mean it's like I can
leave my friend I was talking to her and
she's like you know I don't need no man
and I was like girl don't and this is
why I'm so emotional about it because so
many of our sisters are so lonely yeah
and they don't want any minute and all
they gotta do is just take a chance so I
don't want you to live your life without
fighting to have somebody to say hey or
a lot of the things that you see how
we're divided how we're me is because we
don't have the love that we need
[Applause]
that one consonant you can turn to when
you have a bad day and you don't have to
turn to your girlfriends and your mama
somebody you turn that one person he
understands it looks in your eye that's
the one you keep it I don't care what
[Applause]
[Music]
this is why I keep receipts on people
you're the IRS I gotta say dude okay the
guy with glasses in every anime see what
curry mushed up this whole disco mochi
so just interesting to me that you guys
say this on one hand and in another
video you guys are all supporting her
you're like Lani I'm so happy for ya you
do need this so I'm like which is it
y'all got to stop doing this doublespeak
it's just like when you watch a woman
magazine body positivity the new tran
and often been told that their value
lies in finding a partner and so that
counter to that rhetoric is I'm an
independent woman I don't need no man
and the reality is is there's actually a
middle ground you still need a partner
you still need someone to be by your
side but your entire being is not
defined by that one aspect so just
understand you responded to a negative
stimulus which is women are defined by
the man they choose and your opposite
reaction was I needed man which I
understand words from put the reality
somewhere in the middle you do let's be
clear human beings are not independent
creatures that's all of us that's all of
you I got to give you that point we all
need each other
all right you live in a house they don't
matter how much money you accumulate
someone got to build it you want one or
two run to you someone got a plumbing
you want roads being paved someone got
to do it we all need each other I don't
know why people have to go to the
extreme of this Oh
we say stuff like it takes a village to
raise a child not me because I'm
independent you're not we need each
other and it's not a sign of weakness to
admit that yeah people take it as a yeah
that's what you're saying like you do
like we run a business we want to grow
that business we need other people to
help us to do that find me a good
businessman who says he does everything
by himself and I'll find you a liar
Steve Jobs said that no I'm just I'm
just a I'm the liar okay so and I get it
I get it that dependence is like an
unattractive thing like being overly
dependent on people like being too needy
is is bad keyword overly but we can also
agree on this one fact that if we don't
have each other
nothing functions nothing works human
beings always advance as a society as a
result of groups of people coming
together communities are so important so
I don't know I just feel like me coming
from where I'm from you know you know
especially in Africa you rely on
everyone around you to make sure things
are safe because the police officers
can't get to a lot of places so we look
out for one each other and someone could
be like I don't need y'all but goddamn
life is completely different without all
these people completely different to the
point where it's not even worth living
there's some human females mad and
Marcus his latest Instagram video where
he shared his thoughts about the type of
woman a man really wants take a look
no man no real man one no woman that's a
hundred percent independent you know
it's cool to be self-sufficient it's
cool to be able to get out here and do
your thing and handle your business if
you need so but all that 100%
independent I don't need none type out
of so listen I don't get you nowhere
with us if you don't need me to do
nothing at what you want me for so
ladies do you agree if a woman is fully
dependent and she worthless to a man
when it comes to being in a relationship
with him he just said if you don't want
me to protect and provide what do you
need me for I got a list for love you
time in a loyalty faithfulness
commission so you do need them what do
you need me for I got a list so don't go
around saying you don't you do is on
Love & Hip Hop and he dates on and off
again Brooke Valentine who we've had on
the show here yeah and the reason why
they are on an office because he has
been accused of not being faithful so
that is what from what I understand with
that being said you just touch it's
about to be super pity oh yes yes yes
yes the way the when when a girl when a
girl tastes herself she's about to be
Betty what I understand about this is a
man like this to me from what I'm seeing
in this situation it's just my opinion
if I had to watch this and give it a
diagnosis oh so you want her to not be
independent so that she's dependent on
you stuff when you out doing your mess
she can't go nowhere a do nothing
because she has to sit around and wait
on
no thank you it's archaic thinking and
it's also controlling but I'm just
saying the finding sure that you guys
are labeling this as controlling but
when you guys exhibit the extreme
controlling behavior over your
significant others that's just you doing
the right thing
I love it when our men are vulnerable
and show emotion right
well according to singer Rihanna it
depends what they're crying about that's
right Rihanna posted this meat instead
said if we get together and you die and
you cry you see somebody says and you
start weeping such uncontrollable
emotion when it comes to that person
that you can't even control it to not do
it in front of your current spouse that
you might still have some type of
feelings for that person I agree so so
you so okay hold on you want no hold on
so do you want I don't know why it's so
hard for people to admit that they're
lonely I call it the Barbie syndrome by
certain nature suppose I have a house
and man a dog Kable a pink Corvette that
perfect life and it's not like that
there's a competition with with life
whereas it looks like it's a race but by
that time and people keep comparing
themselves in social media is it now I
don't think it's social media people
have been comparing themselves from ages
is that now it's more in-your-face I see
a bunch of people coupling up with the
wrong people just because they want to
have someone body side I think the whole
point of this is just like you don't
need to overcompensate there's something
okay with being not in your ideal place
but understanding that you know you know
whether you want to say it's a journey
or it's something I'm working towards
whatever the phrase you want to use it's
okay to be in the process and while
you're in the process you don't have to
pretend like you're a finished product
I'm good you're it's okay to say you
know what I'm still in the oven and I'm
still cooking baby no I'm good
no you're not good you're not okay have
you ever try to bite into it on big pie
how is that we're all trying to get to
that point where we find that couple
that you know that relationship that
we're gonna happen it may take you
longer than others it's okay but you
don't have to pretend like you've
crossed the finish line when you haven't
it's not a race you know when you find
people running and then they're running
and they get type so they stop running
but then someone sees them so they start
running here yeah I'm just like booboo
take a walk breathe you don't have to
pretend for everyone else that you
keeping up with the pace I'm good I
start bleeding in a laugh you're not
good not good
don't force it because other people are
watching go at your own pace the world
is gonna consistently tell you that you
aren't doing things fast enough you're
not doing things the right way it'll
come to you when it comes to you it's
just like some people are engaging in
forms of so
reservation that are unhealthy you think
you're protecting yourself but you're
actually destroying any opportunity that
you have at a bright and loving future
they really want to believe fully repeat
it a lot if you repeat something more
than 3000 lights are you trying to
convince me or is really trying to
convince you it's like the people were
like hold me back as it does actually
what they want if I could just end this
on any note I would just say this
you aren't wheat for needing someone who
we need each other
I need you maybe not you specifically
but there's someone out there how
definitely need right man our inbox are
gonna be flooded I know do don't have it
what you talking to me put this out
there and I'm gonna go to messages like
oh I could be your sauce to your patty I
would I wanna yum up your fry your turn
to dance halls eat off your burger and
yell off your fry squeeze off your
burger and numb off your fries long as
you slip on your soda and dip in my
fries I think I say this stuff because I
grew up with a real sense of community
and I recognize its importance I needed
that right and even now today I try to
maintain those bonds with certain people
in my life because I need those bonds
and it's not a weakness for me to say
that and so I just want to say that
today
anything else you want add here
[Music]
every time every time I hear someone
you're not even girls but mostly girls
girls on guys moving out here girls said
I don't need no party what I hear is
someone that that's been hurt and don't
want to get hurt on one and what I
usually say is like super schools I
don't I don't need nobody and I look at
her and I'm like oh you've been hurt and
she's like I don't like you've been hurt
you know what you know what in switches
you know what Instagram quotes say
sometimes the strongest among us are the
ones that are most in need of help I
wish we just had like a really hot girl
with like he's popping out to just
perfectly cap sleep that moment what's
one of those things that she really
enjoyed learning about him that was like
really different the thing that's
different about him is that it's trying
to follow him being better he's still a
man yeah but it's the loyalty that I
like oh you know I mean it's like I
could leave people crying like that baby
laughs I'm sorry
there's nothing words like someone that
is ugly crying it's ugly but someone I
try to keep the composure and still keep
on talking I mean boo boo let it go it's
okay you can cry this is funny one day
being that that I know what I learned
what I learned is just that it's funny
to me I'm sorry it's not funny but it's
just like ya know I what I learned is
relieve is the loyalty the light light
light
here sounded like a creaking door but I
understand what you're saying and once
you find that good good you're like oh
[ __ ] that feels really good and I
understand that that that she liked the
loyalty but yeah that made me tip that
part cuz the girls are getting on my
nerves you know in the soft but never
finish the sentence like I love you so
much
the way he treats you the way he looks
at you the way the way he holds your
hand but you know what we mean you know
that look that look you don't that look
that look exact what I'm good though ok
ok it's like that boys to men song
there's no sounds super cheesy but that
boys to men song where it goes you can't
hope to see the Sun if you don't hope in
your eyes
[Music]
don't let real life pass you by
that's like a really good voice - man
son boy stur man maybe people
[Music]
the harmony were these biggest thing of
the group yo
[Music]